have you ever thought about just doing
just just doing like you know a non-h
manga or non-error manga
i mean i've thought about it but then
like
i just come back to what it can be a
gentile
so every story can be improved by sex i
mean like
if you
if you work it the right way
yeah
just [ __ ] go at it
see that's the challenge right that's
that's that's how do you make sure yeah
how do you do that you know that's
that's the that's the mental stimulation
right
[Laughter]
my god i admire it i admire this the the
determination to be like i want to have
sex in this
i want to try and find every scenario
and turn that into somehow having sex
yeah like after like doing hentai then
like i don't know i at first i thought
like maybe i'll
use it as a stepping stone to do other
stuff
but the more i got into it the more like
the deeper the world got right like the
hentai world yeah like i realized how
much more i could do
in hentai than
once i realized that it's like you don't
have to like step out of hentai yeah you
can do everything you want
in hindi what do you want to do in the
entire world oh my god everything like
oh my god
should have [ __ ]
yeah definitely
it it deserves to have it yeah there's
not enough [ __ ] in space as far as
i'm concerned
like there's never been like a good zero
g like sex scene so far in hand yeah
oh do you have to like you probably have
to research that though right it's like
what kind of different stimuli would a
person be able to get while in zero g's
there are contraptions that people have
developed
to extract each other together
right
right but it's never been tested like in
real life in real life oh wow like
people have been thinking about this
and i've been like watching them think
about it
it's like yes i agree
this is a great idea
oh my god
is it hard to go
is it like a normal thing that maybe
someone will do error manga and then
just go back to doing manga is that like
common in japan or is it kind of like
there are people who do ow manga
then go on to do like nano manga oh okay
some people come back right like the
author uh the author for secure was
originally a uh
era manga uh personal thing or dojima or
like uh um
as well i think that guy clearly wanted
to do porn yeah of course
he didn't know he did he did do
pornography
oh wow so it's actually more common than
that it's very common you get to hang
out with many
other aero manga authors yeah i mean
like
like you know years ago like before you
know kovid yeah i used to go out
drinking a lot like
i used to go out drinking
yeah right yeah yeah yeah and we just
talk about like you know how that shit's
going and like you know like what what
do you want to do next comic what do you
want
yeah yeah yeah so you're like you keep
me awesome
that like the workers must be quite
confused over hearing your conversation
what well they're talking about like
strapping each themselves to each other
in zero g's and [ __ ]
tight-knit community
or how big is the scene right like um i
have no idea like if you
take everybody into account there's like
thousands of people
but if you uh take one publisher for
example
like sometimes they'll throw a party and
people get together all the authors
would just you know introduce themselves
to each other yeah you know build
rapport
and after that you know sometimes we'll
just hang out
so you know
it's cool yeah yeah
cause like i've i've interacted with us
on twitter before and it's so weird he
is legitimately one of the most
wholesome dudes i've ever interacted
with on twitter and i'm like the the
dichotomy between how wholesome he acts
on twitter versus the [ __ ] he draws it's
just like nuts right it's done or do
anything with aero stuff generally quite
chill yeah again i mean you know you
must have some level of clarity yeah
yeah that listening to yourself you're
like i like this yeah i think i think i
think what makes a lot of them so cool
is just the fact that it's like they
have nothing to hide it's like i make
[ __ ] like this you either love it or you
hate it yeah yeah it's not then i don't
really care
yeah
they're like they've like opened up all
their chakras they're just like i don't
even care anymore yeah i think um and
like hentai authors and manga girl are
really good at like separating the
fantasy and their reality
so like you know you might be into like
lowly but like in in your life of course
you're not yeah right right yeah that's
that's good to hear i mean
it's like thank god
i mean it wouldn't it wouldn't be much
of an industry you know
[Laughter]
you mentioned there's thousands of uh
dogen artists
like what percentage of that are able to
do it for like a living
oh
like a fraction
how do you see people like trying to
stand out now or like
oh my god like people
are so much better now
all right
they're so much better now than it was
like 20 years ago yeah
this like it keeps going up and it's
because skill inflation that's i can't
keep up with skill inflation skill
inflation
it is insane you see people drawing
stuff on trains here and even then
they're like like 10 years old and
they're drawing anything better than
i'll ever accumulate through my life
yeah the the the posts i hate the most
on twitter is like when like a dozen
artists or like an artist it's like just
a one-hour sketch and it's like a
[ __ ] masterpiece of the thing i'm
like i
hate you i your art is amazing but i
goddamn hate you
but i wish i could say that no it's it's
the thing i see where like the only
thing that shows up my timeline is like
when artists do like oh a quick one-hour
sketch yeah then they go like complete
the sketch or something and it's just
like a tenth of the interactions i was
like
how does this work
that's why they're only post-working
process like pics now because the only
ones that give any interaction if you
want to be a successful artist on
twitter now don't ever finish your work
yeah just only post the sketches
i know a couple guys who are just like
so much better than me um but they've
never gotten like the no no they deserve
right they can't they can't you know
make a living on like like just drawing
and so they have to work like second
jobs through jobs
it's really depressing that's really sad
like how
what is the main way artists make a
living or hentai artists make a living
nowadays is it still comic or has there
been like a big increase in like say
online patreon oh yeah other i mean like
online
work has just blown up in the past few
years
so i think the mainstay now is just
download like um you know fans are and
the old site yeah
i think it's like maybe like
more than half the market definitely
right right right
yeah because i've definitely seen
especially in the last few years uh in
you know in the western twitter or
western um
industry i guess it's like there's been
a huge explosion of like
patreons and like
especially like even animators like
hentai animators and especially like 3d
artists
people that make overwatch porn are like
the best animators in the world yeah
like pixar yeah i think i wish they
could animate yeah
somehow they all just decided overwatch
will be i'm like i didn't know you could
animate 200 frames a second like that's
that's that's right there it's as smooth
as hell it's like
like they're like
obviously i i've seen like western
side of it but like on the japanese side
it's like a if you are like one of the
top artists is there a potential to make
a lot of money from it or is it still
quite limited on what what you could oh
my i think if you're one of the top like
artists i think nowadays in the next
past few years of course
i think you're having the online
presence is a lot more important than
right
so you know people have like you know
half a million like followers on twitter
or something yeah
and you know i think yeah they can
easily make as much money as they want i
think yeah yeah why not right yeah i
have no idea i mean there's probably
there's probably also a lot of like
dozen artists who have like you know
found success
because of their social media presence
by like doing stuff that's not
necessarily like dojin stuff
because i think like i think asanaki
sensei has like started like
illustrating like a like a regular manga
series or like a line novel series or
whatever it was like that was like
illustrations for novels yeah yeah yeah
yeah so it's like you know there's like
a lot of light novels i know that like
where the illustrations are done by like
doujin artists right like a lot of
people know them
from you know stuff like that right like
you know like pochi for example yeah
yeah yeah yeah like
was just like so massive for him exactly
but even though for her sorry for her
but uh you know but
even though
she did that she still does dogen [ __ ]
yeah you know she's a v tuber now yeah
yeah right yeah yeah yeah
like that that's the next step every
dojo notice is going to be a v shoe yeah
they
now where they just they just live
stream their work exactly
exactly